[Music]
good evening under the three-week
statewide pause governor sissel act said
capacity at bars and restaurants now
need to lower to 25 percent
and there can only be four people at a
table thanks for joining us here at six
i'm denise feltes good evening i'm brian
loftis curbside delivery is highly
encouraged eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo spoke to some valley small
businesses and tells us their plans to
try to get through this
denise and brian i am inside don tortaco
in north las vegas one of the many
businesses concerned
but they're on board with the
restrictions now they tell me they're
going to be doing everything they can
to keep business open
we close ricardo's during the pandemic
on may
15th we spoke to the owner and we
decided to open this place up and we
opened
september 9th with only a little over
two months and catering carlos gomez of
cnc kitchen says
he's hopeful cases will lower in the
next three weeks
but he's also worried we're fairly new
we're a small business
but you know we're struggling gomez is
seeing very little traffic
combined with recent covet numbers he is
getting little sleep
fortunately for us right now because
we're located inside the
rancho discount mall and we're fairly
new we are going to lose one more
table rodrigo ibarra runs operations for
don tortako in march
they got alone to stay afloat word not
not so much struggling a little bit yeah
we have to kind of go out of our way to
see like what new
guidelines apply to us so we're having
to shift around tables
ivara says the majority of customers
dine in for lunch so reduction in
capacity will hurt them
both gomez and ivara need to cut staff
hours and depend
on grubhub postmates and doordash i
wouldn't say we're okay with it but kind
of like rules are rules
we do kind of question their decisions
on how they want to do all these things
regardless they are leaning on the
community
support your local business aside from
you know helping the business you're
also helping it keep it open
and when those people when it's open
they can keep their employees employed
we reached out to the nevada restaurant
association about the 25 percent
capacity
in a statement in part they say in april
at 25 percent dining capacity there will
be little to
no profit in april 20 20 15 percent of
nevada's restaurants closed permanently
due to cover 19 restrictions
we now project that 30 percent of
restaurants will close by the year's end
unquote reporting live in north las
vegas sally caramillo 8 news now